de retour sur le plateau du docu débat
de public sénat après cette éclairante
documentaire alors l' affaire tapie est
elle une affaire d'état une simple
histoire de gros sous ou un véritable
scandale politique et plus largement
qu'en est il de cette république
exemplaire que l'on nous promet depuis
déjà si longtemps nous allons nous poser
ces questions avec les invités et tentez
donc d'autopsié cette affaire
tapie/crédit lyonnais affaire qui dure
depuis déjà près d'un quart de siècle et
cette incroyable personnage un quai
bernard tapie vous vous en doutez vous
pouvez bien entendu réagir sur le
hashtag docu débat et pour en discuter
je reçois thomas clay bonjour vous êtes
professeur de droit à l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin hauteur de code
de l'arbitrage commentait vous êtes un
spécialiste de l'arbitrage nous
expliciter un petit peu en quoi consiste
ce gir bon je compte sur vous elie kalta
vice président de l'association anticor
bonjour alors vous êtes un spécialiste
des questions de république exemplaire
justement vous en parlerai et enfin je
reçois laurent mauduit journaliste à
mediapart hauteur de papier la
république autopsie d'un scandale d'état
vous êtes le co réalisateur de ce
documentaire
alors je vais vous poser une question
laurent mauduit tout bête mais quand on
voit un peu le personnage tapis quand on
commence à s'y intéresser
on se dit franchement que ce type était
un personnage de fiction nom précisément
si je puis dire la différence d'autres
confrères qui ont écrit des livres sur
le personnel lui ne m'a jamais intéressé
d'accord je trouve que souvent dans les
débats publics focaliser sur un homme ça
abaisse le débat public et donc j'ai
toujours eu
je crois comme auto maqué avec lequel on
a beaucoup réfléchi chacun dans nos
métiers sur la faire on l'a trouvée
exemplaires pour une raison c'est qu'on
trouve que tapie fonctionne comme un
miroir cirque au travers de tapis et
quel que soit ccc caractère propre on
lit tous les dysfonctionnements de notre
système on lille vous l'avez vu
l'opacité du capitalisme français jr ya
plein de choses qui se passent en france
qui se passait sous mitterrand ou qui
sont passées sarkozy qui ne se passerait
pas ailleurs dans des pays où l'économie
plus régulé et puis on y lit surtout
tous les dysfonctionnements notre
démocratie évidemment d'abord les
dysfonctionnement innombrables la
justice qui n'est pas indépendante en
france et qui du coup autorise des coups
tordus des coups bas on les voit dès le
début de l' affaire tapie on les voit
encore ces dernières semaines on en a vu
sans cesse les dysfonctionnements du
service des impôts jirs qui va négocier
ses impôts à l'elysée jrada une autre
grande démocratie
en clair voilà on a trouvé enfin moi
j'ai trouvé en chroniquant cette
histoire sur longue date qu'elle était
très instructive sur les maladies
hémolytiques de notre démocratie
d'accord on voit vos échanges vraiment
croquignolesque de sms c'est un jeu pour
lui de jouer avec les journalistes des
tests dans cette espèce de rapport de
détestation de provocation ou on est
vraiment face à de la manipulation
écoutez le dans une presse française qui
parfois peut être corrompue
parfois un qui n'est pas indépendante
tapie a joué parfois de la séduction et
parfois ça marche et je me moque de lui
dans des endiguements la liste des
patrons de presse que vous avez invité
sur votre lieu et c'est vrai que d'après
ce que j'en sais elle est longue mais je
peux vous dire moi c'était pas un jeu
pour quoi faire pourquoi il m'a fait ça
pour une raison assez simple c'est que
évidemment lui a demandé de prendre la
parole dans le documentaire parce que le
dans l'obligation journalistique il y à
l'obligation du contradictoire il a
refusé et je me suis dit mais je me suis
dit qu'après tout je te donnerai
peut-être un peu de gaieté au
documentaire mais c'était pas ça l'objet
c'est que c'était un moyen pour moi de
vérifier d'aller vers lui
voilà ce que je vais dire qu'en pensez
vous cirque et du contradictoire dans le
film vous laissez donc à la fin du
documentaire une liste assez exhaustif
de tout ce qui vous ont refusé
des interviews on y voit christine
lagarde claude guéant pardon non non on
y voit claude bartolone entre autres
est-ce qui vous ont motivé ses refus non
mais là c'est intéressant parce que vous
savez que tapie sadi aussi quelque chose
du système français à des amitiés de
tous côtés donc qui commence à faire
fortune sous mitterrand et il finit de
faire fortune sous nicolas sarkozy
et donc c'est vrai que l'une des raisons
pour lesquelles comment vous dire dans
le système oligarchique français
l'oligarchie et résistante aux
changements et lui a toujours survécu et
en partie à cause de ses amitiés dans
ses amitiés il y en a beaucoup à droite
sarkozy et ses proches que les sortes
feu mais il est aussi un très proche du
président de l'assemblée nationale
claude bartolone c'est claude bartolone
qui va à l'elysée pour convaincre
françois hollande qu'il faut le laisser
racheter la provence voilà donc si l
aspect c'est un homme de réseau et donc
à travers lui on voit les réseaux et on
voit l'aspect très pernicieux de ce
système de capitalisme opaque de qualité
l'isthme consanguins de toute façon on
va on va revenir longuement sur toutes
ces questions mais 22 ans de procédure
et des aller retour de centaines de
millions d'euros plus tard l'homme
d'affaires est à nouveau devant les
juges fin septembre mais alors est ce
que j'aimerais comprendre finalement
c'est on nous parle de procédure
d'arbitrage
thomas clay à quoi ça sert d'avoir
recours à un arbitrage dans cette
histoire
et qu'est ce que c'est l'arbitrage je
vais vous répondre mais d'abord si vous
me permettez
il n'y a pas eu d'alerté pour l'instant
il qu'un aller simple
les millions ils sont passés à l
entraînement public au patrimoine de
bernard tapie
il aurait dû d'ailleurs être demandée
après l'annulation de la sentence
arbitrale qui les a pas rendu parce
qu'on vit redemander donc il n'ya pas de
raisons de procédure est annulée
lui il a eu 403 millions d'euros mais
entre temps on lui demande pas de rendre
l'argent
il touche la somme dans la suite de la
sentence arbitrale rendue le 7 juillet
2008 et cette sentence va mettre
quasiment sept ans être annulé puisqu'il
devait être annulée le 17 février 2015
alors lorsque l'acte est annulé l'argent
obtenu grâce à la doit être restitué cet
argent n'a pas été restitué
l'enjeu de l'audience du 29 septembre
c'est précisément de savoir à qui
appartient cet argent voilà bernard
tapie dit que dans seulement sur lui
appartient mais qui pourrait même avoir
quelques centaines de millions de plus
et l'état considère que cette taxe est
cet argent doit lui revenir le plus vite
possible
donc ya pas eu d aller retour voilà u11a
les syndicats il y aura probablement un
retour sans vouloir préjuger est alors
la question que vous posez c'est est ce
que vient sur l'arbitrage dans cette
histoire vaches cette question j'ai
envie de vous la retourne et je ne sais
pas ce que vient faire l'arbitrage dans
cette histoire on avait une procédure
qui suivait le circuit normal habituel
républicain qu'est le circuit judiciaire
avec des décisions qu'on appelle même
une décision de la cour de cassation et
même de l'assemblée plénière de la cour
de cassation qui est en quelque sorte la
formation suprême de la formation
suprême je parle sous le contrôle des
magistrats eric alt ici présent on
revenait devant la cour d'appel on était
devant la cour d'appel
en septembre 2007 cette année en trois
mois par hexion de nicolas sarkozy et
c'est à ce moment là qu'on décide de
retirer la sphère du circuit la cour de
cassation ayant annulé la décision
favorable à bernard tapie et de la
transmettre à un tribunal arbitral
l'arbitrage c'est pas fait pour ça
l'arbitrage c'est la justice des
affaires est souvent des affaires
internationales c'est le site du
commerce international pour des litiges
entre sociétés de nationalités
différentes qui vont choisir un tribunal
arbitral composé souvent deux
personnalités éminentes et elle-même de
nationalités différentes qui vont rendre
une sentence arbitrale et cette sentence
a ras la valeur d'une décision de
justice
l'arbitrage n'est pas fait pour
détourner la procédure judiciaire dans
un conflit avec forte relents politiques
instrumentalisée par le pouvoir
politique de l'époque
alors eric alt je me tourne vers vous
pourquoi est-ce qu'on est arrivé à cette
procédure
d'arbitrage alors qu'on n'aurait pas dû
finalement je ne sais pas plus que les
autres c'est ça un des mystères de la
sphère qu'il faudra bien saoulé cioni un
jour je crois qu'en des dans cette
affaire un certain degré d'incandescence
de la corruption de la république toutes
les pathologies de la démocratie sont
résumés et or passage entre le privé et
le public pour résister entre le privé
public continuité entre la gauche et la
droite esprit de caste une certaine
arrogance du pouvoir et là on a quelque
chose qui était un peu trop voyant et
donc la roue de roue a tourné pour
bernard tapie provisoirement en tout cas
alors on voit bien que énormément de
personnalités politiques se sont
inquiétés dans cette affaire la liste
n'est pas exhaustive mais entre
christine lagarde stéphane richard qui
sont dans son directeur de cabinet on a
eu claude guillon n'a eu brice hortefeux
nicolas sarkozy qui navigue un petit peu
tout là-dedans inquiété pour l'instant
l'espagne n'est pas un truc c'est qu'il
lui était présente la république à
l'époque en tout cas où la sphère
démarre vraiment parce qu'aujourd'hui et
que voilà qu'en fait ça commençait six
mois du tout oui en fait ce qui est très
intéressant même temps terriblement
impressionnant dans le fonctionnement de
de l'état c'est que on se rend compte
que comme l'a dit thomas en 2006 l'état
était presque sur le point sans doute de
gagner ou pas été dans une position
judiciaire très avantageuses
le cours de la justice ordinaire et est
suspendu et donc se met en place c'est
ce que la justice les magistrats
instructeurs ont établi les juges
d'instruction qui enquêtent
il ya un groupe qui se forme dont
l'ambition c'est en tout cas la
suspicion de la justice et de fraude et
l'arbitrage d'arranger l'arbitrage est
donc de les soupçons des magistrats
porte sur quelques personnes qui
lui-même son avocat l'un des arbitres
qui reste au pouvoir je trouve moi qu'il
ya le comportement d'autres arbitres
soulève également
parce que c'est bon pour pour être clair
laurent mauduit ça veut dire que quand
on met en place une procédure
d'arbitrage ont choisi les arbitres oui
parce que ce sont les partis qui décide
à l'image d'un jury américain de m untel
untel et untel qui voulaient l'arbitrage
s'est fait lorsque l'entreprise
française conclu avec l'entreprise
américaine qui est un litige
l'offre de l'entreprise française veut
un français là l'entreprise américaine
veut un américain et les deux arbitres
vont choisir un troisième arbitre à
cressat le modèle de l'arbitré il est
absolument indispensable arbitrage danse
à certains grands contrats
internationaux
quand eurodisney s'implante en france
c'est la condition qu en cas de litige
on aille à l'arbitrage quand la france
un plant le louvre à abu dhabi c'est à
la condition qu en est-il gens se
retrouvent pas dans la justice d'abou
dhabi serait bien que c'est qu'elle
figure n'ont rien à voir avec cette
affaire
l'arbitrage est la victime collatérale
d'affaires alors là on a donc installé
des arbitres qui ont été décidées par
les autorités dont on a découvert
ensuite au départ de l'instruction
judiciaire que certains d'entre eux ont
manqué leurs obligations n'étaient pas
indépendants notamment l'un des arbitres
qui reste souple on a découvert ans
ensuite qu'il avait travaillé auparavant
dans d'autres arbitrages avec l'avocat
de bernard tapie
et donc voilà il ya des soupçons aux
multiples sur plusieurs personnalités et
je vois juste m'attarder sur une
personnalité en particulier une enquête
est mise en cause
un qui est l'ancienne liste des finances
christine lagarde
l'actuel patron du fonds monétaire
international et kate est mis en examen
devant la cour de justice de la
république
une exception finalement d'exception
l'aspect stupéfiants qui montre aussi à
mon sens le les dysfonctionnements de la
justice et que le procureur
la cour de cassation qui a émis un avis
à destination les produits justice de la
république a requis un non-lieu
oui je trouve l'histoire stupéfiante
pour quelles raisons c'est que imaginons
que christine lagarde est était de bonne
foi qu'elle ait eu recours à l'arbitrage
sans savoir qu'il aura pu être frauder
il ya dans l'histoire de l'arbitrage
un événement stupéfiants c'est que en
novembre
2007 je parle sous le contrôle de thomas
clay on a connaissance du fait que l'un
des arbitres been 2008 pardon a manqué à
son obligation d'indépendance en
l'occurrence on sait qu'ils restent donc
là qu'on fait d'intérêts normalement la
ministre des finances avait la
possibilité si elle était de bonne foi
de dirar on a un problème on a payé on
doit 405 millions d'euros à tapie mais
je découvre que l'un des arbitres n'est
pas indépendant je demande la récusation
de l'arbitré donc l'arbitrage peut être
annulée
or non seulement elle ne fait pas jouer
leurs accusations mais en plus elle le
cache à l'assemblée qui au même moment
l'interrogent ouais c'est quand même un
dysfonctionnement gravissime dans notre
démocratie
on a les résultats de l'arbitrage qui
sont un indicateur d'alert 400 millions
et 45 millions d'euros pour préjudice
moral
alors généralement un préjudice moral
c'est cent mille neuf cent mille euros
pour des faits graves et l'a 45 millions
d'euros va prend pour les pour un nom
qui est écrit sur une poubelle
il ya là manifestement un excès est un
indicateur d'alerté et pourtant malgré
tout cela lorsqu'il est question d'agir
contre l'arbitrage bien consortium se
voir refuser donc il ya un ordre qui
requis un ordre de refusé d'attaquer
l'arbitrage
oui il faut quand même dire
qu'aujourd'hui cette sentence elle est
annulée
elle est annulée par la cour d'appel de
paris dans un arrêt rendu le 17 février
2015 qui est absolument accablant à la
fois pour les trois arbitres
pour l'avocat de bernard tapie maître
maurice lantourne pour bernard tapie
lui-même un peu moins d'ailleurs pour
lui pour son avocat et qui dénoncent la
fraude donc sous les la vérité
judiciaire
alors non ça c'est le volet pénal dans
le volet civil
la sentence est annulé pour fraude
il ya une faune gros dos en civil il ya
un impact frauduleux entre les
différents acteurs de cette affaire
et aujourd'hui c'est la vérité c'est à
dire qu'on peut dire sans rien risquer
sur votre antenne ses arbitrages étaient
frauduleux d'ailleurs bernard tapie
lui-même l'a reconnu devant les juges
d'instruction dans l'une de ces deux
démissions récentes
voilà de l'interrogation est de savoir
si je te mets juste le propose en ce
moment qui a participé à la fraude
donc il ya six personnes mises en examen
pour escroquerie en bande organisée vous
savez qu'il ya une personnalité qui a
été entendu mais pas encore mises en
examen qui est claude guéant l'ancien
secrétaire général de l'elysée novembre
nous vous entendons est-ce que c'est
dans son bureau que se font les
premières réunions l'elysée en juillet
2007 pour lancer l'arbitrage lumière qui
les dernières celles qui décident de ne
pas appliquer la sentence est par
ailleurs est une question se pose c'est
s'il ya eu une bande organisée avec des
complicités à l'extérieur de l'état mais
aussi à l'intérieur de l'état quelle est
la nature de la relation entre bernard
tapie et nicolas sarkozy et nicolas
sarkozy qui reçoit je vous le rappelle
on l'a découvert lors de la saisie chez
nicolas sarkozy de ses agendas qui
reçoit bernard tapie à huit reprises
entre janvier 2007 et juin 2007 hier
avant même l'élection présidentielle il
reçoit sans cesse leurs tapis dans la
vie des affaires n'est plus rieur et
dans la vie politique n'est plus rien et
donc l'enjeu de l' enquête judiciaire
donc ça ou au delà du volet civil qui
est au centre du débat le 29 septembre
l'enjeu du débat judiciaire c est qu
elle qui a participé à la fraude
et si une bande organisée qui est dans
cette bande et c'est seulement les huit
ou est-ce qu'il potentiellement est-ce
qu'il y en a d'autres
alors dans le cadre de cette procédure
civile
le président de la chambre civile de la
cour d'appel donc chargé d arbitrage a
été nommé il y a quelques jours
à sa grande surprise à la cour de
cassation une promotion pour celui qui a
annulé donc cet arbitrage jean-noël
acquaviva est ce que ça vous étonne et
puis finalement qui décident de ça le
fait qu'on extirpe comme ça de la
procédure
la personne qui s'est rendu responsable
de cette annulation est ce que on doit
pointer christiane taubira c'est super
de la magistrature qui décide des
nominations à la cour de cassation sur
ce point il ya un communiqué du
président de la cour de cassation je
n'ai pas de raison de ne pas le croire
c'est la procédure normale qui a suivi
son cours
il était lui même très étonné d'avoir
été nommé
dire aussi les propos du président
acquaviva c'est que c'était un magistrat
c'est un magistrat reconnu comme étant
un excellent spécialiste droit de
l'arbitrage par tous les spécialistes
et c'est vrai que lorsqu'il a rendu son
arrêt le 17 février qu'il a mis une date
pour l'examen du fond de l'enfer au 29
septembre ça pouvait on penser que c'est
une date relativement courte un délai
relativement court ce qui laissait
penser que lui même pensait qu'il
statuerait sur le fond de la décision
comme c'est moi qui a révélé la jeune
athlète à faire une observation c'est
que dans les deux tours on a vu plein de
dysfonctionnements de la justice de 1993
jusqu'à l'arbitrage au frauduleux moi ce
qui me stupéfait c'est que si on met
comme des petits cailloux les faits qui
se sont accumulées depuis ces dernières
semaines mois ne laisse pas de
m'inquiéter où je les trouve intrigant 1
il ya un changement du président qui
était immergée dans le dossier j allais
faire tapis ses 20 ans d'affaires c'est
éminemment compliqué donc un successeur
est nommé qui doit connaître en trois
semaines tout ce dossier
pas seulement le président il nécessaire
en train de dire que finalement le jeu
termine juste le mât remarque est par
ailleurs j'ai révélé également que le
parquet a décidé par avance de ne pas
assister à l'audience du 29 septembre ne
pas insister sur le parquet donc mais
thomas clay magistrats pour le dire
mieux que moi doit dire doivent veiller
au respect de la loi et il n'y va pas
parce qu'il a fait savoir aux parties
que c'était à son sens une affaire
privée
il ya 405 millions d'euros d'argent
public cette voie là donc c'est à dire
que la justice française n'est pas
indépendante
non moi je ne peux pas dire ça je
considère que je suis française est
indépendante et les calques pourra
peut-être avoir une une position comment
dire statutaire mais moi qui ne suis pas
magistrat je peux dire que je considère
que la justice est indépendante
simplement pour reprendre ce que vient
dire laurent mauduit il est tout à fait
exact que l'absence du parquet à
l'audience du 29 septembre à fait
étonnante
le parquet lui n'est pas indépendant
parce qu'on parle justice en paca si ce
qui rend les décisions est tout à fait
étonnante s'agissant d'une affaire où il
les intérêts sont évidemment pas
seulement des intérêts privés
c'est les finances publiques qui sont en
jeu c'est l'intérêt général mais en plus
il ya des contres des questions de
droits relativement sophistiqué qui se
pose est sûre le hac sur lesquels on
aurait aimé entendre l'opinion et
l'analyse juridique du parquet oui je
crois que dans la démission de monsieur
acquaviva les choses sont normales mais
il ya tellement d'anomalies dans cette
affaire que même ce qui est normal
suscite l'interrogation une
interrogation effectivement c'est
étonnant le parquet vient souvent à
l'audience de leurs clients qui sont
d'ordre public
là il n'ira pas et ça pose plus
généralement la question savoir si les
intérêts de l'état sont bien défendus
dans ce dossier alors en parlant
l'intérêt de l'état je voudrais qu'on
réécoute notre ami henri guaino qui se
faisait une réflexion finalement quelque
peu normal sur ce dossier c'est claude
guéant a effacé les impôts des valeurs
tapis ce n'est pas conforme à ma
conception de l'égalité des citoyens
devant l'impôt pourquoi est ce que vous
avez semé partisans on mélange tout
laissons tout en laissant les sons les
impôts des impôts annoncée à 6 et messi
60e tapis c'est tout à fait rayonner
tout tout tout les toutes les fortunes
de france négocié leurs impôts vous le
savez pardon alors comme ça moi je peux
aussi aller au ministère du budget est
allé négocier mes impôts les
associations puissant après la fir
cahuzac
les associations vont poser la question
de ce qu'on appelle le verrou de bercy
dire la possibilité de négocier les
impôts et la possible de négocier aussi
le montant des amendes
puisque c'est le ministre en charge du
budget qui a le monopole de l'action
publique en la matière le parquet n'a
aucun pouvoir si le ministre n'oublie
pas de poursuivre eh bien je crois qu'au
plus haut niveau de l'état il a été
décidé que nous verrons à bercy seraient
maintenus
là on a un indicateur dallaire de la
persévérance dans que ça parce que
pourquoi est ce que je me suis autorisé
à dire ça ce soir là sur france 2 c'est
que j'avais produit au préalable
sur mediapart un enregistrement de
bernard tapie dans lequel il racontait
qu'il avait été négocié ses impôts même
pas au ministère du budget ou avec le
ministre ce qu'il avait fait mais aussi
avec claude guéant à l'elysée et donc de
cesser beaucoup plus encore que le leu
leu leu bercy qui a le pouvoir ce qui
est assez choquant de dirigeants déjanté
des enquêtes s'il ya des fraudes
fiscales c'est là c'est ce soit que
modérée du coup c'est la clé du mystère
pourquoi est ce que c lagarde et
d'autres ont dit au début de la faire
vous inquiétez pas c'est pas grave il
n'y aura que 30 millions d'euros qui
reviendront à tapis dans sa poche
or au total on sait que la somme a été
sans doute dix fois supérieur aux 1 200
bons pour quelles raisons c'est parce
qu'il ya une tractation fiscale et c'est
dedans
le l'enquète juillet à commettre les
trois magistrats chargés de l'enquêté
il vérifie aussi le rôle de claude
guéant dans la négation fiscales donc
c'est une irrégularité stupéfiants sac
l'administration des eaux et accepte se
dessaisir et que ce soit le souhaitent à
généraliser qui est qui cet extrait que
vous avez passé est assez symptomatique
parce que il montre la perte totale de
valeur on a quand même quelqu'un qui
était conseiller personnel ce projet
sans titre du président de la république
deux précédents et qui nous dit sur une
chaîne du service public que oui on peut
les négocier c'est un pur évidemment ça
lui a échappé parce qu'en principe on
n'a pas le droit d'aller négocier ses
impôts mais que lui qui en plus est
c'est d'incarner de manière très
maladroite parfois la république nous
disent que finalement on peut les
négocier ses impôts c'est absolument
significatif je crois d'une perte de
valeur et anglaise certaine forme de
déréliction de nos institutions
alors justement à ce propos françois
bayrou convoi dans votre documentaire
dit à un moment il est normal que les
puissances s'exonère des règles du
commun tout du moins il le pointe
est ce que c'est quelque chose de
particulièrement français est-ce qu'on a
ça chez nos voisins étrangers comment
expliquer cette espèce de deux
sentiments de hors sol et qu'on puisse
se permettre alors qu'on vote les lois
d'être au dessus des lois
c'est tout le problème du prado son
république la république
principe c'est l'égalité devant la loi
c'est au fronton de tous les temples
républicain est là pour le coup il ya un
certain décalage entre les principes et
la pratique et c'est tout l'enjeu des
citoyens et que de faire en sorte que
cette indignation puisse se transformer
à un moment ou un autre et c'est tout
l'enjeu des citoyens que de réfléchir à
l'architecturé des pouvoirs à la façon
dont fonctionne la vème république en
décalage avec les principes qui la fonde
quand
du coup françois bayrou nous dit qu'il
n'est pas d'accord avec cette idée elle
c'est à dire que la plupart des hommes
politiques en france sont plutôt assez à
l'aise avec cette consanguinité entre
les milieux politiques les milieux
judiciaires médias une tradition
française qui a une spécificité
française parce que la consanguinité
entre les élites financières et
politiques existent partout aux états
unis vous souvenez de bush et sa
proximité avec les pétroliers et les
grands groupes pétroliers
la singularité de la france et que aux
états unis un grand scandale
il est nos relations des pouvoirs et une
force des contrepoids qui fait que dans
un scandale du type tapis c'est sur les
bureaux du congrès six mois après il ya
des rapports vous savez tout en france
huit ans après le début du scandale
tapie s'était toujours pas purgé parce
que on a pardon un parlement qui est
très faible 1 par rapport à ce qu'est le
congrès américain il n'y a pas eu de
commission d enquête parlementaire parce
qu'il ya une presse qui est faible ou
souvent à la botte et donc das a vu
tapie n'a vu tapis que sous l'angle
people et pas sur l'objet d'une enquête
les contre-pouvoirs jeu un point dans le
film le rôle cour des comptes - des
comptes la cour des comptes fait un
rapport sur les irrégularités y restent
sombres
il est révélée parce que voilà il est un
citoyen qui me leur mais avec huit mois
de retard 8 mois de retard lors de danse
ont consigné des faits qui sont sans
doute des fautes pénales et donc ça
sinon je trouve que c'est l'année milla
démocrate faut pas considérer pas jeter
l'opprobre sur le personnel politique de
manière générale je pense que cette
affaire est au contraire symptomatique
de la permanence de certains hommes sur
une vingtaine d'années
aussi bien dans les milieux d'affaires
que dans les milieux politiques mais
c'est une poignée et finalement est ce
qui était intéressant se demander
comment cette poignée arrive à être en
1992 1993 aux affaires et en 2012 encore
aux affaires
elle c'est pour ça que je pense qu'il
s'agit plutôt de dérive personnelle bien
identifiés et la justice nous dira de
qui exactement
il s'agit plutôt que une dérive générale
du pardon thomas clerc on a eu entre
temps la sphère cahuzac là on a en ce
moment là faire bygmalion alors même si
c'est pas du même ordre on a eu thomas
thévenoud fin des affaires on en a tout
le temps vous pouvez pas dire que c'est
les mêmes quand 92 98 en 2008 et qu'en
2015 on a quand même du renouveau dans
ce que je dis dans l'affairé tapie ce
qui est intéressant c'est la permanence
des personnes concernées et ça c'est
tout à fait significatif il yad'autres
d'affaires mais elles sont pas toutes à
mettre sur le même plan d'affaires la
serre tapis c'est une dysfonctionnement
généralisé de l'appareil d'état et la
perturbation de la justice judiciaire au
profit d'une seule personne
quelques dysfonctionnements particulier
par exemple dans l' enquête pénale
il ya un volet ministériel devant la
haute cour de justice
et puis un volet classique qui est
instruit par les juges d'instruction on
voit que la justice fonctionne sur des
rythmes différents qui aura peut-être
des solutions différentes alors que
manifestement entre le cabinet le
ministre il y a des liens évidents et
que je n'imagine pas que le cabinet faso
des initiatives prennent des initiatives
ou si importante sans avis de la
ministre donc haute cour de justice qui
pose problème
la suppression de la haute cour de
justice était promise la haute cour de
justice et cour de justice est une
juridiction d'exception et un cour de
justice de la république est une justice
d'exception qui juge les ministres dans
le cadre de leurs fonctions
la suppression de cette cour et demander
de puiser des romans mm je crois bien
d'autres lisent de mémoire j'ai droit
constitutionnel et même cet aspect
relativement minimaliste de réforme des
institutions
eh bien elle est enlisée je ne parle
cette affaire ce point que suda vérité
très juste le dossier est éclatée entre
multiples procédures pénales civiles
cour de discipline qui fait qu
objectivement c'est très
compliqué de s'y retrouver n'arrive en
suisse au jour le jour on y arrive mais
il ya un point qui effectivement
extrêmement inquiétant sur le
fonctionnement de notre démocratie c'est
que pour une même affaire
une même infraction on va avoir un
ministre et un dirigeant directeur de
cabinet qui en principe n'agit que sur
les ordres du ministre l'un renvoyé
devant la cour de justice de la
république dont le moins qu'on puisse
dire est que l'instruction un peu
toniques n'est pas la marque de fabrique
et l'autre qui va se retrouver devant le
justice qu'en l'occurrence le sénat
garde un côté salon stéphane richard qui
pour être clair est aujourd'hui à la
tête d'orange
oui je termine parce que christine
lagarde se retrouve mise en examen pour
négligences et encore le parquet une
fois de plus ici le même parc côtier
d'ailleurs demande qu'ils ne soient pas
renvoyés enfin qu'il n'y ait pas ce
qu'est un non lieu alors que son
directeur de cabinet lui il est
poursuivi excusez du peu
pour escroquerie en bande organisée et
pour détournement de fonds publics donc
là il ya quand même un éclatement du
dossier on voit d'ailleurs la même même
problème dans l' affaire karachi qui
n'est absolument pas normal
oui alors je voudrais qu'on avance parce
qu'il nous reste quelques minutes
comment on fait pour mettre en place un
système qui soit plus transparent qui
laisse moins l'ouverture à une forme de
clientélisme de mélange des genres
est ce qu'on peut imaginer quelque chose
qu'il faut prendre exemple
c'est nos voisins du nord de l'europe
d'abord on s'interroge sur la monarchie
républicaine sur ce pouvoir d'un seul
qui se réplique tous les stades de
l'état on s'interroge sur le rôle du
parlement sur la composition du
parlement aussi sur la possibilité pour
le parlement de prendre des initiatives
et commission denquête on s'interroge
sur l'indépendance de la justice sur la
façon dont les procureurs sont nommés
voilà ça c'est le minimum
institutionnels qu'on peut faire je
constate que jusqu'à présent on attend
toujours que ce minimum institutionnel
qui était pourtant notamment rappelé par
la commission jospin pour un renouveau
démocratique
sony mais ce minimum institutionnels
n'existe pas alors ensuite il ya je
pense d'autres espaces de démocratie
d'autres lieux du politique inventée
mais on ne le fera pas si ce minimum
institutionnels et pains complets alors
sans aller jusqu à revoir tout ça quand
moi je m'interroge compte dans certaines
municipalités type levallois perret
patrick balkany est condamné à cinq ans
d'inéligibilité et qu'il est réélu quasi
au premier tour je crois une fois qu'il
peut revenir devant les électeurs ce qui
est pas aussi pardon je vais être clair
une tradition française et qu'on aime
une cette forme de clientélisme est une
monarchie républicaine ce peut être un
modèle patrick balkany comme non mais en
attendant il est quand même rêver c'est
à dire ce qui est assez intéressant
c'est de voir que malgré le piètre long
du gave été condamné thibault inéligible
et fait cinq ans d'inéligibilité mais il
est quand même réélu donc sk pas une
question aussi de culture antique or
lors des lois qui ont suivi le scandale
cahuzac avait proposé qu'on raisonne
pour les candidats des élections
politiques comme les candidats à la
fonction publique
donc il y ait un casier judiciaire
vierge conditions d'aptitudes pas une
sanction conditions d'aptitude et bien
quelques députés
quelques sénateurs nous ont suivis mais
à la fin le ministre a dit il ya
peut-être un risque constitutionnel et
tout le monde a été très content de ne
pas prendre ce risque constitutionnel si
passionnant on est dans les locaux du
sénat la réforme institutionnelle que
appel à eric alt de ses voeux elle est
bloqué ici parce qu'il faut une majorité
des trois cinquièmes pourquoi est ce que
les sénateurs et les députés ne
s'entendent pas sur des sujets la
suppression de la cour de justice de la
république ce n'est pas un sujet
politique politiciens
est un sujet démocratique le statut du
conseil supérieur de la magistrature qui
est aussi dans le projet de loi
ça devrait être bon quoi on garantit ses
intérêts finalement aujourd'hui c'est
bloqué c'est bloqué pour des raisons
partisanes pour des raisons
politiciennes et c'est c'est absolument
tragique pour notre démocratie un autre
exemple aux poursuites parce que je suis
d'accord avec ce qui a été dit sur
l'impérieuse nécessité d'une refondation
démocratique nous prenez donc chacun des
volets de cette histoire vous voyez des
éléments possibles une réforme je
continue à liszt à cour des comptes pour
passer d'un rappeur est opaque
pourquoi est-ce que le république
n'impose pas une règle souffre etc sauf
quelques rares exceptions la
transparence et la règle géré à l'heure
d'internet d'achat l'open data mais
pourquoi est ce que tous les rapports
planète côté laurent mauduit vous êtes
la preuve vivante ici que et mediapart
ont également que finalement aujourd'hui
les compliqué de casser encore quoi oui
sauf que vous voyez bien quelle est la
situation dramatique de la presse est
racheté par des grands oligarques avec
le manque d'indépendance n'existe pas
dans d'autres pays et donc ça participe
du même problème dans une société
démocratique il ya une presse
indépendante la france fait totalement
exception l'etac totalement à
contre-courant
et puis le rambo du fait un travail
exceptionnel et il faut le souligner
aussi bien dans ses enquêtes dans ses
livres que dans ce reportage
mais il n'ya qu'un seul laurent mauduit
ça suffit pas pour faire tenir tout la
démocratie ce n'est pas vrai je prenais
à la libération dans les réformes
démocratiques porté par le conseil
national de la résistance il ya une
presse libre et indépendante
il n'y a pas de démocratie forte sont
des citoyens éclairés et donc le la
dépendance la presse participe de donc
je récapitule indépendance dans la
presse
indépendance de la justice de manière
claire refonte
institutionnel qui permettrait plus de
transparence plus de pouvoir au
parlement plus de transparence et le
citoyen là dedans des contre-pouvoirs
plus alors c'est je crois que citoyen
doit pouvoir agir mais c'est tout le
symbole d'anticorps on peut maintenant
agir devant la justice mais une
association aussi vigoureuse et tonique
soit elle ne peut pas remédier à des
dysfonctionnements institutionnels
donc on peut jouer un rôle d'aiguillon
oui on ne peut pas se substituer à des
institutions qui ne fonctionne pas bon
bah écoutez merci messieurs de nous
avoir à nous avoir éclairé sur cette
question qui a effectivement vraiment
pas simple merci à tous de nous avoir
suivis je vous rappelle notre adresse
mail si vous souhaitez réagir à
l'émission est toujours le hashtag docu
débats sur twitter et a très vite public
sénat
enfin